this is the biggest protest in myanmar
since 2007. tens of thousands of people
on the streets of yangon saturday saw
huge pro-democracy crowds
today they swelled even further
filling roads and flooding squares
[Applause]
the military claimed monday's coup was
for the good of the country
the country doesn't seem to agree
[Music]
myanmar's pledging democracy wasn't
perfect
but many people aren't prepared to let
it down
[Applause]
we are youths we have a future teenagers
chant at police as yangon medics
cheer on the passing crowd
in mandalay bikers carry the people's
message
while six thousand marched together in
chin state
people from different backgrounds and
areas united
in their fight people so frustrated you
know enough is now this is too much now
we have been
seeing this 50 years 60 years 70 years
how long it's going to go
we need to do something now so there is
a mentality of the youth as well
and youth in burma is really determined
they are
democratic love freedom human loving
people they are
very they are hope of the future of our
country
but in some places the authority's
patience is wearing
thin shots are fired in the air
as police dispersed demonstrators in mia
wadi
near the thai border
feeding fears a bloody crackdown could
follow
they ban a life rohingya children they
raped thousands of rohingya women this
is what happened
so the people of brahma should
understand
what's happened to the rohingya this is
the same military they
they committed genocide against our
people so the same time
the burmese military can heal protesters
and can crack down and brutality can
come to them
new pockets of anti-coup protest are
popping up
across the country with every passing
hour
with more strikes planned for monday it
feels like the crisis in myanmar
is escalating towards a crescendo and
neither side
is willing to back down siobhan robbins
sky news